a very big shake-up today on president
Trump's legal team as lead attorney John
Dowd resigned Trump reportedly was
displeased this weekend when the
attorney called on the Justice
Department to end the special counsels
investigation huh
well another conflict was exposed today
when Trump said that he favored what
Dowd had opposed
would you like to testify the special
counsel Robert no sir I would like to as
in talk to the special counsel but is
the president walking into a trap
let's ask two of the sharpest legal
minds out there emeritus Harvard Law
Professor Alan Dershowitz author of the
book the case against BDS why singling
out Israel for boycott is anti-semitic
and anti-peace and in San Francisco
attorney Harmy Dylan who's a national
committeewoman for the RNC for
California great to see both of you
professor Dershowitz in Harmy we've
talked about this issue it sends a chill
down my spine and up nice line as a
former defense attorney to hear about
how the president wants to go in and
talk to Muller press or Dershowitz what
are the pitfalls here well you know what
I couldn't believe is what I heard on
television shows that he actually
offered a job to be his lawyer to bob
bennett bob bennett i wonder if anybody
told him was the lawyer who got bill
clinton impeached bob bennett was the
lawyer who told bill clinton it's okay
you can testify at a deposition about
your sex life and that's what got him
impeached he could have easily settled
the case for $750,000 I called it the
greatest legal blunder of the 20th
century and and Bob Bennett was offered
a job to come and become Trump's lawyer
I don't know what's going on in that in
that White House he of course should not
testify unless he absolutely has to and
if he has to it should be under the most
rigorous restrictions of time and type
of questions and he should be prepared
to answer yes no I don't recall that
giving long long answers because the one
thing they're trying to get them on is
perjury and that there's no defense
against that perjury is one of those
specified in the Constitution for
impeachment and that's the one issue
that has to be avoided at all cost
full disclosure actually I work for Bob
Bennett at Skadden Arps many many years
ago I didn't work on that case but I
didn't work for Bennett at Skadden Arps
her mate I would ask you about this you
know that the big swirling controversy
is oh no lawyer wants to work for Donald
Trump well a lot of law firms big law
firms don't like getting involved in
these big political matters for a
variety of reasons and Trump you know
everything's very toxic now but this is
what the former acting Solicitor General
General for Obama said today let's watch
I represented bin Laden's driver but I'd
have trouble representing Donald Trump
and the reason for that is very simple
which is you know the guy doesn't
believe in the rule of law that's coming
that's coming from the Obama
administration with the way they of
course handle the Hillary email
investigation and so forth but Harmeet
your reaction to this what about written
answers to questions what about just
very narrow area in which Donald Trump
would answer questions could that be
acceptable or is that another as
professor Dershowitz says perjury trap
perhaps well I think it's less of a
perjury trap if the president answers
written questions but it causes its own
problems I mean for one thing I don't
think the president the United States
setting aside whether it's Donald Trump
Bill Clinton or whoever should be
answering questions like this from a
special counsel unless there is clear
evidence of a crime and also is showing
that he's the only person who can answer
those questions absent that this is a
perjury trap and it does trouble me as a
supporter of the president that he wants
to talk to special counsel under these
circumstances that is absolutely a
perjury trap and I think that one of the
frustrations here of his lawyers and
other lawyers is that maybe the
president isn't following the sound
advice of some of his lawyers which is a
serious problem and you know a lot of
lawyers would have a problem with a
client who isn't following good advice
Gersh wits that's a big issue right
because Donald Trump such a strong
personality yes he's been his own
advisor and been pretty successful in
doing that time after time when people
said no he said yes yes and he usually
wins but the law is a very different
deal
and so you can talk about that you're
managing a client that doesn't want to
listen it's very very difficult of
course but I love what the former
Solicitor General said he wouldn't
represent that old Trump because he
doesn't believe in the rule of law but
he represented bin Laden's driver
none of these no criminals generally
don't believe in the rule of law if that
was the basis for not representing
somebody all of us criminal lawyers will
be out of business
that's a phony argument I think this the
better argument is that it's hard to
represent a client who doesn't listen to
you who doesn't take your advice I don't
I think the president's doing something
very strategic by the way I think he has
good cop bad cop he has the good cops
who were trying to make a deal with the
special counsel so limit his exposure to
limit the kinds of questions but then
he's also preparing bad cops Joe
digenova who can get on television who
can go to court who can help litigate I
don't think that's such a bad strategy
the problem is somebody like doubt
didn't want to be caught in the middle
of that he wanted to be in control of
the strategy and he wanted to play only
good cop I also think I was gonna say I
agree with Allen but you can't be both
the good cop and the bad cop and Dowd
had the situation or last week he was
calling on the white house count on the
special counsel to you know limit his
investigation and you can't be that same
person who's negotiating the terms of
the interview of the predator so yeah he
can't have it both ways
I do think also and I agree with that I
also think guys it was that time but you
also have to bring in people who are not
sometimes in their late 70s early 80s
again not to me it's not ages this is
but you've already been asked this
question it's important to bring in
people who are are you know in the end
of prime and I have experience and so
forth I know he's interviewed Emmitt
flood who's an old coal clunker mine
phenomenal Williams and Connolly
attorney you can put together a team
that has senior statesman lawyers you
can have a little bit younger and bring
that
left out one group what you left out one
group a Bordeaux and he must include
women women on his defense team you mean
to have women on a defense team
absolutely you young people you need
people of color you need people who are
women you need people from every
background you don't know what you're
gonna get when you get a jury you don't
know what judge you're gonna pull you
must be prepared for every eventuality
look we know that they put the case in
the District of Columbia because they
wanted a particular kind of jury rather
than the Virginia jury both sides have
to be able to play that game and get the
maximum advantage out of the differences
in jurors differently smart fence
counsel different reason maybe not
against Donald Trump but against some
against some of the other people by the
way my colleague Larry tribe has now
changed his mind and says you can you
can actually prosecute a sitting
president and he had previously when
Clinton was president said you can't
prosecute a sitting president I think he
was right the first time not this time I
don't think you can prosecute a sitting
president though it's not clear as a
matter of law yeah well we'll see but I
think he has got to get the best team in
place I don't care what color you are
what your background is but women
attorneys
Harmeet they're really smart so that's
why I want to bring them absolutely
fantastic